assassin assassin brigands voleurs
encore assassin à la raison ouvre ses
images parce que c'est des vraies photos
de criminels qui date de 1897
elles ont été prises par cesare lombroso
un des tout premiers criminologue
il faut savoir qu'à l'époque la
criminologie c'était un peu trash parce
qu'on pensait que les criminels c'était
des humains mais un peu saoul d'évoluer
et on les étudier comme si c'était une
autre espèce animale quoi francis galton
un autre chercheur de l'époque lui il
faisait des portraits composites
alors ils mélangent et des photos de
criminels pour faire ressortir le visage
moyen du criminel de base
donc ça par exemple c'est le visage
moyen d'un meurtrier obtenu en
mélangeant les visages de huit meurtres
y est différent et ça c'est le visage
moyen d'un voleur donc c'est vachement
pratique distille à l'époque parce que
tous les gens qui ressemble à peu près à
ça et ben on peut les emprisonner tout
de suite
même s'ils ont rien fait parce qu'ils
portent sur leurs visages la signature
biologique du crime
alors évidemment ce n'est pas comme ça
que ça marche sinon il ya longtemps
qu'on aurait emprisonnés disons philippe
etchebest et franck ribéry quoi alors
cette approche qui d'eric de la
phrénologie elle a complètement disparu
heureusement mais l'idée de pouvoir
anticiper les futurs crimes a resurgi
récemment grâce à une branche de la
foule aux copies qui s'intéresse au
comportement collectif des criminels
alors je vais vous expliquer tout ça
dans cette vidéo on va analyser ensemble
tous les crimes qui ont été commis à
chicago on va faire des simulations
numériques avec mon invité surprise et
on va se pencher sur les réseaux de
criminels à los angeles
allez c'est parti c'est l'épisode 11 de
foule aux copies
dans minority report le film de steven
spielberg ce sont des créatures les pré
cogs qui ont des visions des crimes qui
vont se produire dans le futur et tom
cruise est chargé d'interpeller les
futurs criminels avant qu'il ne passe à
l'action
je vous arrête pour le futur meurtre de
sarah marque de donald devine que vous
alliez connaître aujourd'hui 22 avril à
8 heures et quatre minutes du match
j'ai rien fait alors non prédire le
crime avec des visions c'est pas
possible
là il ya des images sur moment par
exemple il va faire beau
non c'est vraiment pas possible par
contre on peut développer des modèles
mathématiques qui sont capables
d'estimer le risque qu'un crime se
produise à un certain endroit dans un
futur proche
si vous voulez c'est comme une sorte de
bulletin météo mais pour les activités
criminelles quoi tient d'ailleurs ça me
donne une idée ça
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous le week-end s'annonce
mouvementée avec un taux d'agressions
très élevé pendant toute la matinée les
homicides seront supérieures aux
normales saisonnières avec notamment un
braquage qui va mal tourner dans le
nord-pas-de-calais le harcèlement de rue
sera toujours très présent sur
l'ensemble du territoire
je vous souhaite à tous une excellente
journée bon allez on arrêtait blacks je
vais vous expliquer comment ça marche
et pour ça il me faudrait des données à
analyser alors je vais regarder tout de
suite sur google si je peux trouver un
genre d'art chiffres de criminologie
ça a l'air pas mal ça alors ici j'ai les
données de la chicago police department
voilà j'ai l'impression d'être dans une
série américaine alors on va télécharger
ça pour 2018 français ou si on a
vraiment attaqué bienvenue à chicago
quoi bon je vais zoomer sur un petit
quartier de la ville sinon ça va prendre
trop de temps voilà autour de harbin
parc et on va regarder tout de suite à
quoi ressemblent ces données voilà donc
chaque point rouge c'est un crime
et quand on voit ça on se dit que
franchement c'est impossible de prédire
quoi que ce soit et bien en fait si je
vais vous montrer que si on se penche
sur le comportement des criminels eh
bien on peut anticiper chaque jour une
partie des crimes qu'ils vont avoir lieu
le jour suivant
alors ce sont les travaux d'une femme
qui est devenu en quelques mois la pire
ennemi des gangsters de chicago non ce
n'est pas dana scully
ce n'est pas non plus debra morgan c'est
la mathématicienne andrea bertolini
[Musique]
andrea berthod dit elle a réussi
anticipées probablement des milliers de
crimes grâce à un seul outil
cette équation en fait l'inspiration
géniale de bertozzi c'est qu'elle a
repris la même équation qui permet aux
sismologues de décrire les tremblements
de terre le truc avec les tremblements
de terre c'est qu'ils se produisent pas
n'importe où n'importe quand la très
grande majorité des tremblements de
terre sont causées par un précédent
tremblement de terre on appelle ça des
répliques
et bien pour le crime c'est la même
chose la majorité des crimes sont en
fait des sortes de répliques de crimes
précédents
en fait ce qui se passe c'est que si
vous avez pas
exemple un cambriolage qui se produit
ici à un moment donné et bien dans les
jours qui suivent le risque d'un nouveau
cambriolage autour de ce même lieu sera
très important et ce risque s'estompe
progressivement avec le temps
c'est l'idée que le crime appelle le
crime et effectivement c'est une
tendance qu'on retrouve très facilement
dans nos données de chicago ici par
exemple vous avez la fréquence de
cambriolages dans les jours qui suivent
un premier cambriolage et dans le même
quartier et pour comparaison ça c'est la
même cour mais cette fois pour les
répliques sismiques
après un tremblement de terre en fait
les criminels ils se comportent un peu
comme dans cette simulation que je vous
avais montré dans une précédente vidéo
la plupart d'entre eux sont des suiveurs
qui vont reproduire ce que les autres
ont fait précédemment et on retrouve les
mêmes tendances pour les vols les coups
de feu le trafic de drogue et même les
violences conjugales avec des échelles
de temps un peu différente à chaque fois
alors la bonne nouvelle c'est que ça eh
bien ça rend les comportements criminels
relativement prévisible à court terme
si je reprends mes données de chicago et
bien maintenant je peux tracer chaque
jour une carte de risques criminels pour
le lendemain il me suffit pour sa
d'ajouter l'équation de bertozzi dans
mon programme
voilà on va mettre les paramètres qui
sont proposés dans la publie ok voilà
donc ce que vous voyez maintenant à
l'écran ce n'est pas le crime
enregistrées chaque jour
mais les zones de crime prédit pour le
lendemain alors j'ai pas fais l'analyse
statistique complète parce que là ça
prendrait trop de temps quand même
mais d'après les auteurs la méthode est
extrêmement efficace alors ce qui est
hallucinant avec ses découvertes c'est
la vitesse avec laquelle elle s'est
transformée en application quelques mois
après la publication la police de santa
cruz contacter un des auteurs jeffrey
branding âme pour lui proposer de faire
un test grandeur nature sur le terrain
les résultats sont bons le programme
s'étend à d'autres villes américaines et
jeffrey banting a créé le logiciel près
de paul qu'il vend aux communes
américaine pour quelques dizaines de
milliers de dollars
et tu veut pas le vendre toi ton
programme quoi je parle vendre ton truc
là au lieu de glander sur youtube
celui-là
ce logiciel près de paul il fonctionne
exactement comme je vous ai montré à
excuser moi désolé de déranger salut
salut cyrus dis donc j'étais en train
d'écouter là c'est un peu black mirror
ton truc non c'est pas black mirror là
c'est juste un petit modèle qui prédit
les futurs crimes
quoi qu'est ce qu'il ya bah c'est
raciste quoi sert un site
les machines jacinthe hi-fi ciel robocop
tout ça c'est ainsi c'est bien connu
tout le sait même matt damon et c'est
que c'est raciste
non c'est plutôt le contraire en fait le
programme il va avoir tendance à
corriger les biens humain qui existe
déjà chez les policiers
si tu veux on fait des simulations tu
vas voir c'est clean jeu trop chaud je
suis trop chaud en plus j'adore quand
les dissimulations une oasis chose ok
mais après tu me laisses finir ma vidéo
d'accord produits oui ok allez on lance
matelas alors regardons va simuler un
monde imaginaire avec des gens qui ont
disons la peau bleue et des gens qui ont
la peau verte et ces gens ils vivent
dans des quartiers différents
ça c'est le quartier majoritairement
bleu et ça c'est le quartier
majoritairement vers le taux de
criminalité c'est le même dans les deux
quartiers et donc on peut simuler jour
après jour les crimes qui se produisent
dans cette ville voilà ici chaque point
rouge c'est un crime alors maintenant on
va mettre des policiers et on va dire
qu'à la base les policiers ils sont pas
complètement neutres ils vont un peu
plus souvent patrouiller chez les bleus
que chez les verts on va mettre 55 45
alors les bleus ils se sentent un peu
discriminer forcément et là je vais
simuler l'algorithme de près de paul qui
va envoyer les policiers là où le risque
est le plus important sans tenir compte
de la couleur de peau et je te parie
cyrus que ce petit billet il va
disparaître et qu'on va revenir à 50 50
attention regarde bien ce qui va se
passer baum maintenant
attends que ce qui se passe là voilà
bail sont racistes
non mais attends et sont pas racistes là
c'est un programme informatique qui y
voir un bug non non c'est du racisme
anti bleus c'est tout ouais en fait t'as
raison
au lieu de corriger le biais
l'algorithme est de près de paul l'a
amplifié regarde je t'explique le truc
c'est qu'on a une sorte de cercle
vicieux qui s'est mis en place
plus on en voit des policiers dans un
quartier plus les chances de détecter
des crimes dans ce quartier seront
importantes
du coup quand il ya un tout petit peu
plus de policiers chez les bleus au
début le programme enregistre plus de
crime chez les bleus alors qu'en fait
c'est juste qu'ils ont été un peu plus
observé que les verts on appelle ça un
billet d'échantillonnage du coup on en
voit encore plus de policiers chez les
bleus ça amplifie le biais et ainsi de
suite
et dans la vraie vie vous l'avez compris
ceux qui sont victimes de cette
discrimination
ils n'ont pas la peau bleue mais plutôt
la peau foncée il faut qu'on a qu'on
puisse lui est bien du frais banting
amis c'est quand même bien fait
incendier dans les médias à cause de ça
et lui propose d'ajouter un contre-pied
dans le programme pour forcer une
affectation des policiers proportionnel
à la taille de la population
donc s'il ya 50% de bleu et 50% de verre
eh bien on force la moitié des policiers
chez les bleus et l'autre moitié chez
les verts
sauf que si on fait ça on va réduire
d'environ 10% le nombre de crimes qui a
été correctement prédit
parce que des fois on en voit des
policiers là où le risque était moins
important du coup le programme est moins
efficace
alors est-ce qu'il faut une police
efficace ou une police juste et bien je
vous propose tout de suite d'écoutés
jeffrey branding gamme qui s'expriment
sur ce sujet
et bien en tout cas moi je vous laisse
vous faire votre propre avis sur cette
question et je remercie cyrus si vous
connaissez pas aller voir sa chaîne ce
mec c'est un vrai cyborg
alors je vais vous montrer une autre
découverte très importante mais pour ça
il faut d'abord que je vous parle des
crazy as mexique les crazy as mexicaine
c'est un gang de la banlieue est de los
angeles dont l'activité criminelle a été
étudié en détail en 2001 les chercheurs
ont référencé toutes les fusillades
entre ce gang élégant voisins comme par
exemple les white fence leyti n'diaye ou
encore les quattro flatte ainsi que les
territoires qu'ils occupent dans la
ville alors pour bien vous expliquer
cette découverte va vous représentez ça
sous forme d'un réseau de rivalité entre
les gangs
alors ce point au milieu c'est les crazy
as mexicaine et à chaque fois qu'il ya
une rivalité connu avec un autre gang
par exemple avec les white sands je
trace unis entre les deux et comme j'ai
toutes les données dans la publier bien
je vais faire ça pour toutes les
rivalités connu voilà et je vais mettre
la taille et la couleur des points
proportionnelle au nombre d'agressions
que le gang a commis le truc c'est que
les autres gangs sais pas non plus des
enfants de choeur et eux aussi ils se
tirent dessus régulièrement par exemple
et quattro flat ils se sont aussi
embrouillé avec les white fun c'est avec
les hasarde et ainsi de suite
et en fait des gangs dans cette banlieue
y en a pas seulement 12 y en a une bonne
trentaine et je peux donc compléter ce
réseau pour avoir maintenant toutes les
rivalités entre eux tous les gangs de
los angeles est alors cette
représentation en réseau ça a permis aux
chercheurs de découvrir quelque chose
d'important
si on regarde à quelle date se sont
produites les attaques disons entre les
quattro flats et les white funds on
obtient ce graphique alors ce sont de
vraies données 1 qui ont été collectées
sur une période de trois ans est ce
qu'on voit c'est que c'est clairement
pas aléatoire on a des périodes où les
attaques se répète rapidement
entrecoupées de périodes de calme et en
fait ça c'est exactement comme pour les
cambriolages ou pour les tremblements de
terre
dès qu'une première attaque a lieu entre
deux gangs le risque d'une suivante
immédiatement après va augmenter on est
dans une logique d escalade de la
violence
eh bien
la première découverte fascinante qui a
été fait grâce à ce réseau c'est que ce
risque d'agression il se propage de
proche en proche
donc s'il ya une attaque par exemple
entre les quattro flat et les white
fence ça augmente aussi le risque pour
qu'il y ait dans les jours qui suivent
une attaque entre tous les gangs voisins
par exemple entre les cloîtres flat et
les hasarde qui pourraient elles mêmes
entraîné une attaque des crédits as
mexicaine et ainsi de suite
c'est comme si on avait une forme de
contagion dans les fusillades et ça
c'est l'idée centrale qui va être
généralisée à tous les crimes par le
sociologue andrew papachristou ce nom si
oui oui un excellent chien
le single papachristou s'il se dit eh
bien si ça se trouve cette logique de
contagion
ça s'applique pas juste aux gangs mais à
tout le monde il est donc parti
récupérer les archives de la police et a
retracé le réseau d'interactions 270000
criminelle regardez moi cette beauté ici
chaque point est un criminel et de
criminels sont connectés s'ils se
connaissent et dans ce réseau on peut
mettre en évidence des cascades de
propagation d'attac par arme à feu dans
cet exemple une première personne se
fait tirer dessus puis quelques jours
plus tard c'est au tour d'un de ses amis
qui entraîne de nouvelles attaques parmi
ses amis et ainsi de suite
au final c'est 34 personnes qui sont
victimes indirectement causé par la
première et certaines cascades implique
encore plus de monde
la bonne nouvelle avec ça c'est qu'on a
des outils en épidémiologie pour décrire
et même prédire les phénomène contagieux
du coup papa christophe va faire de
l'épidémiologie criminelle par exemple
dans ce réseau le meurtre se propage
comme un virus
avec un nombre de reproduction de 0,63
ce qui est une valeur relativement
faible bien heureusement sinon ce serait
la guerre civile à chaque fois qu'une
personne est victime d'une attaque par
arme à feu immédiatement ses contacts
deviennent sujets à risque pendant une
durée de 84 jours à getcha d'amis
enfin le taux de transmission dépens de
certains critères individuels comme
l'origine ethnique ou l'appartenance à
un gang
alors si on sait à peu près anticiper et
gérer une épidémie est bien est ce qu'on
pourrait pas faire la même chose avec le
crime c'est la mission que s'est fixée
un médecins virologues reconverti en
criminologie gare is love king slatkin
essaye de prédire qui seront les
prochaines victimes d' attaque par armes
à feu et les met littéralement en
quarantaine pour interrompre la cascade
de propagation
chaque meurtre éviter ne sauve pas une
seule vie mais toutes celles qui
auraient pu être perdu dans la suite de
la chaîne de propagation
d'après cette conférence la technique
est extrêmement efficace puisqu'elle
aurait conduit à une baisse de 67% des
attaques dans une banlieue expérimental
de chicago voilà alors est-ce qu'on est
dans black mirror ou est ce que la foule
aux copies va définitivement en finir
avec le crime est bien en ce qui me
concerne le mystère reste encore entier
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous le week-end s'annonce
mouvementée avec un taux d'agressions
très élevé pendant toute la matinée au
départ
et tout de suite la météo des plages une
classe
demain nous gagnerons deux minutes de
valérie damidot je vous souhaite à tous
une excellente journée
tout le monde le sait même madar annoncé
que c'est raciste
non mais abonnez vous avez dit [ __ ]
folle aux copies bien sûr bien su en
chaîne de qualité
ciao